[Music]
valentine's day is a week from sunday
don't delay in getting something special
for your loved one
our friends at florica tour have you
covered they have something for everyone
let's welcome back michelle how are you
michelle
hi j.c how are you great great good to
see you you have
sent some decorations over for us now
this year many of us will be spending
valentine's night in
how can we create a cozy evening this
year
so we've got a lot of great things here
in our studio and one of them is the
crate that you've got there in studio
and i'm holding here
and it includes your petals and candles
and matches
we've got some fantastic boxes of
chocolates which are perfect
for the perfect valentine's day and
creating the overall coveted
romantic quarantine experience for
valentine's day this year
now these boxes i love these boxes
because you can customize these boxes to
kind of fit your
your loved ones their needs and desires
i guess you could say
absolutely so like we have another one
over here that's geared specifically for
a kid
so it comes with a teddy bear and
chocolates and popcorn
has a tic-tac-toe cookie in it so really
fun ideas
to be able to share with your kids um
show them share the love with them
bring that valentine's experience home
all the way around so everybody in the
family gets to be a part of it
there's so many things i love about you
guys is first off your flowers seem to
last
forever you have the best roses in all
of las vegas maybe the west of the
mississippi
but i see here in front of me you have
some succulents which i think is a great
idea because these will last
such a long time absolutely so a lot of
what we do and what's here in our design
studio downtown
are the succulents you've got there the
little hoya plant which looks like a
heart
perfect for another gift that's easy for
a friend for a family member
anything along those lines that's really
fun and different but we are
full of plants and succulents and
terrariums we have so many fun concepts
and ideas to make it really great and
easy for the holidays
the plant there you've got the sucka for
you is perfect
because it's great for family or friends
now let's talk about ordering because
this year's a little bit different are
people starting to order stuff early
should people start ordering today
people should start ordering right now a
lot of florists including us across the
nation are actually going to be capping
their flower orders this year
simply because covet has impacted our
industry so heavily across the board we
have had farms close
we've had growers and wholesalers close
across the country
so we are really still recovering on the
floor aspect of it
so we're encouraging everybody to order
very early get your orders in so that
we can account for you make sure that we
have your files you've got the
limit quality quantity and everything
across the board
thank you so much michelle now to place
your order go to floractor.com happy
valentine's day to you mercedes over to
you